[Música]
con nuestro primer invitado el día
hablamos de la conferencia sobre la
biodiversidad de la ONU y la cop 15 los
datos señalan que la actividad humana ha
afectado el 75% de la masa terrestre y
el 66% de los océanos también que se ha
perdido más del 85% de los humedales y
que el 25% de todas las especies están
amenazadas de extinción estos datos
deberían preocuparnos pues se lo
preguntamos a nuestro primer invitado
del día Maximiliano bello asesor de
políticas públicas oceánicas de Misión
Blue y también participante en esta
cumbre de la biodiversidad cop 15
Gracias por estar con nosotros esta
mañana de miércoles Maximiliano y
digamos la importancia de esta Cumbre y
esta cifras alarmantes desde estos datos
oficiales que acabamos de leer
Hola Raúl sí efectivamente estoy acá en
Montreal donde estamos siguiendo la la
reunión cierto de las partes de la
conferencia de de biodiversidad y donde
se discute efectivamente el salvar
cierto la diversidad del planeta que la
Estamos perdiendo sabemos hoy día que
hay básicamente si tú empezaras la vida
en este planeta hay mucho más vacas o
hay mucho más humanos cierto que
cualquier vida Silvestre prácticamente y
hemos llevado al colapso a muchísimas
especies a la extinción en muchísimas
especies a lo que algunos llaman cierto
de alguna forma el antropoceno es decir
Nosotros somos la principal causa de
cambio en el planeta y por eso ayer por
ejemplo en la apertura el mismo
presidente fue muy enfático en alcanzar
cierto consensos para poder avanzar en
no perder más esa diversidad que
mantiene la vida del planeta
Maximiliano estamos muy tarde ese para
actuar esta cifra se pueden revertir o
digamos que se van a mantener y lo que
podemos lograr es que nos sigan
aumentando qué es lo que va a pasar con
respecto a Esto justamente la idea acá
es tener cierto acciones precisas
es tener cierto algunos objetivos que
nos pueden guiar para poder revertir esa
situación que aún es posible cierto
tenemos aún la capacidad primero de
cambiar Pero además Tenemos muchos de
los elementos de la naturaleza que están
todavía presentes y por lo tanto la idea
de esto es justamente asegurar que esos
elementos sigan presentes uno de los
temas más claves lo menciono también
ayer el secretario de la nacionalidad lo
mencionó el mismo Primer Ministro crudo
es el 30% es alcanzar justamente un
consenso en la meta al 30% de la
protección por ejemplo de la Tierra como
del océano qué se tiene que hacer
Maximiliano para alcanzar ese 30%
tenemos que llegar las partes Tienen que
llegar a un consenso tienen que
flexibilizar también hay algunas partes
que efectivamente no están todavía
arriba justamente de ese 30% que no
están
que no quieren llegar a ese 30% como
objetivo y por lo tanto hay
negociaciones en curso de distintos
países en eso en los países
latinoamericanos creo que están jugando
un rol muy importante que en los últimos
años hemos visto por ejemplo un avance
muy importante en las creación de áreas
marinas protegidas
es uno de los ejemplos que aparece más
constantemente aquí cierto en la
conferencia y por lo tanto esos países
están empujando Pero hay otros países
cierto que aún no están claros de que se
debiera ser la la
Maximiliano qué tan difícil es alcanzar
a este consenso vimos también las
dificultades que tuvieron los
negociadores en la cop 27 en Egipto para
llegar a un acuerdo final se retrasó
precisamente también esta Cumbre porque
no había no se habían puesto de acuerdo
a los países podemos ver más unidad en
esa cumbre de la biodiversidad
desde el día
viernes de todo el fin de semana hemos
estado negociaciones la la realmente
abrió digamos oficialmente ayer pero
mientras tanto los grupos de trabajo han
estado avanzando y se nota que que
todavía no estamos eh cierto están
disponibles para poder seguir avanzando
en alguno de los temas Lamentablemente
hay algunos países que están tratando de
retrasar o enlentecer la discusión y
también de minimizar esa ambición
necesaria y Y lamentablemente también
algunos de los mismos países que lo han
hecho en en otras como en la de cambio
climático y y Raúl Esto es algo muy
clave en lo que pues estamos en el
triple crisis crisis la triple crisis es
cambio climático es contaminación y es
pérdida de biodiversidad Esta es una
parte clave para la solución como lo ha
sido también el eh la solución al cambio
climático y como también al al plástico
de toda la contaminación que ya
conocemos muy bien las tres tienen que
ser atendidas de la misma forma y para
eso necesitamos ambición una ambición
que hoy día Yo lamentablemente todavía
no estoy viendo
voluntad política también
Maximiliano digamos porque esta negativa
de de esos países a no estar dispuestos
a lograr este consenso general hay
intereses económicos también de por
medio que retrasaría esto hay mucho
interés económico acordémonos por
ejemplo en el caso de los océanos cierto
la creación de las áreas protegidas es
clave sabemos hoy día que la principal
amenaza de esto para los océanos es la
sobreexplotación que está que está
debida eh básicamente por la por la
pesca no es decir eso produce la la
pérdida de biodiversidad y lo que hoy
día estamos viendo que algunos todavía
quisieran seguir como decimos
ya no podemos estamos en una crisis de
insertos donde Estamos perdiendo los
elementos como decía el inicio que
mantienen la vida y que nos mantiene
finalmente a nosotros la humanidad en
este planeta por lo tanto si no
realizamos cierto las acciones y en este
caso Llegamos todos de acuerdo
difícilmente cierto vamos a poder pensar
en un futuro para la humanidad